pas de gauche
il y avait des amis puis certains sont partis sont arrivés
Il s'avère que c'étaient mes amis
puis nous sommes devenus amis avec eux avec d'autres
amis qui sont venus ici pour bien vivre
tout le monde est parti
[musique]
aller se promener avec quelqu'un avec des amis
les amis ne suffisent pas et tout le monde en aurait au moins un
ami était accroupi
[musique]
Je ne pense pas parce que je ne sais pas quoi
sera dans une heure dans une journée
vous ne pouvez pas deviner ici
[musique]
trois fois par jour on mange chez nous d'ici
nous venons alors, eh bien, ils sont venus manger
Ate est venu Ate est venu
[musique]
nous vivons sans eau
sans internet
beaucoup sont au chômage
qui sont maintenant au moment où ils
juste survivre maintenant
les gens tuent tous les jours comme d'habitude
tu lis les infos tu sais tout
[musique]
C'est ma terre c'est ma maison pourquoi suis-je
devrait le jeter
Je veux vivre chez moi tout seul
terre et pas où
Peut-être devriez-vous penser au fait que quelqu'un
parti qui n'appartient pas ici
maison
vivre avec leur famille
[musique]